[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos
bienvenidos a este canal de las américas
de hoy viernes 30 de agosto es un gran
placer estar con todos ustedes acá en
este momento un cordial saludo a los que
están en la pantalla detrás de las
cámaras y detrás de los micrófonos
nos encontramos aquí en el estudio 26
como les gusta que yo lo diga amigo
leonardo en el estudio 26 de radio
canadá no me reía porque me parece que
esta mañana desayuno pablo desayuno
cordero
[Risas]
raro distraído como bueno hoy en
compañía de paloma martínez y leonardo
que menos de vacaciones y dos fotos de
las vacaciones tengo un millón de fotos
de las vacaciones pero no las amo
hoy no tenemos tiempo desafortunadamente
pero habrá tiempo porque tenemos todavía
por delante tres semanas más de castor
en las américas
tres semanas porque bueno como se habrán
podido dar cuenta tenemos invitados hoy
en el estudio se trata de rodrigo
velasco artista plástico y de maritza
rosales argonz a ellos están aquí porque
lo primero que todo bienvenida y
bienvenidos
y ellos están aquí porque hay una
la exposición colectiva que se presenta
a partir del 5 de septiembre próximo y
bueno pues ellos justamente nos van a
hablar de esa de esa exposición más
tarde entraremos en
en el tema con ellos y ahora
[Música]
yo tengo unas efemérides tú tienes miles
de palomas dos semanas me dijo hace
mucho que no se le corresponden
entonces no las ahora menores dentro de
lo insólito acá en este programa antes
de entrar en materia tenemos las
efemérides de nuestro querido leonardo
que en realidad no son tan insólitas
pero me gustaría contarlas bueno una de
ellas el primero de septiembre o sea
mañana que pone este programa de estar
mañana y el domingo y el lunes
en el sitio de internet se cumplen 80
años de que los alemanes tirarán la
primera bomba con la que comenzó la
guerra y la seguridad mundial y
recordada en este caso fue en polonia
una pequeña ciudad polonia donde esa
ciudad pasó a llamarse la pequeña
gernika porque en el desastre que
hicieron con ese bombardeo los alemanes
fue más o menos lo que cuenta el cuadro
guernica de picasso
entonces se le llama vía primera del
prado en madrid ahora cuando esto pasa
una cosa terrible con el guernica de
picasso porque yo fui a esto una vez
allá lejos y hace tiempo en parís
fui al look y cuando fui a ver a la
monalisa me esperaba un cuadro
extraordinariamente gigante excepcional
algo raro a grito de morondanga de este
tamaño no no tiene que acercarse mucho
para ver a muchísima gente si no hay un
cordón de seguridad
alarmados y toda la cuestión de los
paneles para el reflejo para el flash y
ver si fue una complicación cuando fui
al reina sofía a ver el guernica de
picasso lo había visto pequeñas
reproducciones cuando entre el guernica
de picasso que se impone en una pared
entera que había recién llegado de una
muestra de un
del moma y habían decidido no moverlo
más porque en el viaje había recibido
algún tipo de movimientos raros y se
había trabajado entonces lo van a
restaurar y no moverlo más del móvil
bueno otra de las cosas que pasó en esta
semana el 23 de agosto se celebró el día
del radioaficionado en uruguay así que
muchos años y el 27 de agosto el día de
la radio en argentina y tiene que ver
con la primera emisión de radio para
mucha gente
exacto
pero lo importante es que hay una
grabación o sea si hay una grabación de
eso esas son las efemérides efemérides
dio el 23 de agosto de 1998
y llegué yo a montreal
ya es una semana de la llegada
mencionando a esta semana 21 años pero
además de eso tú tienes algo insólito
que contar maspalomas y es un señor en
columbia británica que se llevó un susto
y para salir de ese susto hizo para
nadie que nadie debemos hacer eso
alimentó a un animal salvaje en este
caso un oso porque este señor estaba
paseando por ahí y encontró un oso en su
camino verdadero oso perezoso no para
bueno no sé por qué era muy parecido
simpático elos al final porque si miráis
a la foto de a poco no se ve tierno de
hecho el señor mismo le tomó la foto al
osito y está ejecutando el darle de
comer a ese oso en la boquita cómo están
ustedes viendo y esa bolita de más cita
que está ahí
es muy tradicionalmente canadiense son
unas bolitas de masitas que venden en
una de las de los restaurantes de comida
rápida y de café más importantes del
país el que es típicamente canadiense
tim burton's y venden eso para los niños
a los niveles en que los adultos
bueno pues este señor salió del paso y
se salvó del oso dándole bolitas de más
y está muy azucaradas y salomón martín
bits al a los a los entonces bueno lo
peor de todo no es que le diera eso
sino que es muy peligroso él está en
peligro porque nunca hay que alimentar a
los animales silvestres ninguno pero
además le salió caro el chiste porque
los team beat son muy baratos es fuerte
pero la multa por haber hecho es fueron
dos mil dólares
bueno pero entonces es por eso entonces
los dos mil dólares le salieron carritos
pero entonces no hay que hacerlo
independientemente del animal
independientemente lo que le quiero no
de dar de comer no hay que darle de
comer que los gemelos o el animal y que
reclame el pase que ese es el problema
después bajan a pedir comida como están
acostumbrados a que uno les dé comida
entonces bajan a pedir cuando bajan a
pedir se ponen agresivos y tienen rabia
por son portadoras de rabia y entonces
por eso hay que tener cuidado yo me
acuerdo lo que nos había dicho alguna
vez en costa rica
no fueron costa rica fuimos atacados por
marquitos y estos magos
no no no pero venía teniendo dos o tres
y nos vieron y nabai que el himno saca
con el centro foto foto de forma normal
con la marca que lo marcar prisión así
nos sacaron una bolsa o entraríamos las
toallas y se fueran porque reconocen que
dentro de la voz de la bolsa de alimento
nos decía uno de los cuidadores que eso
es porque durante muchísimo tiempo la
gente les debe comer entonces ellos
asocian en esa bolsa hay comida y roban
cualquier cosa para sacar comida porque
más fácil venir y robarle a un turista
desprevenido que ir a buscar una banana
por ejemplo
y lo pasa con este tipo de casos es que
es muy probable que estos animales se
acostumbren si uno les da a repetición
se acostumbre a venir a buscar comida
entre los humanos y cuando no haya se
pongan agresivo con el furioso efecto
bueno entonces algo que no hay que hacer
no pero de todas maneras la posibilidad
de que nosotros nos encontremos un gozo
por ahí ambulante en montreal es muy
poca encontrar si pero no muy lejos de
montar pueden encontrar a bueno yo les
quiero hablar muy rápidamente de
de algo insólito también sí y que
sucedió en edmonton
en el montón y resulta que eso sucedió
es que tienen un vídeo de eso
no no tengo le preguntamos a soler
lo que va a tardar mucho tiempo eficaz
pero en todo caso este es un señor que
se llama bon ton y se ganó la lotería el
loto max el 26 de octubre del 2018
entonces el año pasado el 26 de octubre
del año pasado se ganaron la lotería y
cuando él verificó su tiquete de lotería
se dio cuenta que lo hice lo había
ganado y no supo qué hacer en ese
momento y prefirió quedarse callado no
decir ni siquiera a su familia le dijo
que se había ganado 60 millones de
dólares y 12 860 millones 2
y ahora tiene una explicación eso porque
en realidad el ticket tenía un ganador
el ganador de los 60 millones y tenía
una jugada gratis del extra dos billetes
212 dólares y otros 60 millones pero lo
curioso en esta historia
insólito es que bueno cualquiera se
vuelve alegre y le dice a todo el mundo
y él se quedó callado durante 10 meses y
es que la mujer no sabía los riesgos y
de pronto porque él decía que no sabía
cómo iban a reaccionar la familia como
entonces empezó a hacer pruebas a quien
me quiere por lo que soy que me quiere
por la plata
después que se decidió la semana pasada
de
de decirle a la familia que eran
millonarios entonces ahora pues ya están
organizando los viajes de vacaciones y
yo leí que lo que va a hacer es pagar su
hipoteca lo que le falta por pagar de la
hipoteca y seguir trabajando porque le
gusta trabajar
muy trabajador se sienta a trabajar dejó
el micrófono y me voy a nosotros
bueno entonces regresamos nuevamente acá
en el programa con nuestros invitados
nuevamente bienvenidos a marisa y a
rodrigo y en la exposición scottex
traverse si lahm se cómo podríamos
traducir eso en español marisa suelo
trans iría como códices
travesía del silencio o atravesar el
silencio si entonces háblanos un poco en
qué consiste tú eres la curadora de esta
exposición sí muchas gracias por la
invitación eso es importante para los
artistas para los proyectos poder hablar
lo más posible de lo que se está
haciendo y en este proyecto en
particular codex es un ejercicio de
reflexión no sé si ustedes saben
seguramente lo saben este año es el año
de las lenguas indígenas y queríamos en
el marco del festival latín arte que
tiene ya 11 años de realizarse aquí en
montreal
queríamos abordar también este tema y
entre otros el tema de la travesía que
es un tema que es muy actual
con todos los flujos migratorios que
cada vez son más en el centro de las
discusiones y geopolíticas queríamos
hablar en este proyecto de cómo hay
códigos y referencias culturales
que permanecen a través del tiempo y que
caminan con nosotros que atraviesan el
tiempo el silencio en el sentido de que
algunas voces no fueron suficientemente
escuchadas hay presencias que han sido
más bien restringidas sobre todo si
hablamos del mundo indígena en este caso
son artistas tres artistas de origen
mexicano que trabajan con referencias e
imaginarios de los códices o de las
culturas mesoamericanas por supuesto con
una visión actual con toda esta noción
de travesía del silencio de la de estas
culturas que no han sido invisibilizadas
necesariamente pero también con la
travesía del espacio del tiempo de la
permanencia de estas voces también
queríamos abordar en este en este
ejercicio trabajos muy actuales que van
desde
prácticas digitales pero también que
pasan por tradiciones ancestrales y
tradicionales como la artesanía la
pintura la noción del color que tienen
nuestros pueblos latinoamericanos hay
que decir que también es un imaginario
compartido en general en la américa
latina que no es exclusivo a méjico y
como todo esto en la época de la
mundialización permanece a través de una
voz resiliente y que aparece en
múltiples formas y que celebran estas
estas herencias culturales herencias y
no materiales y en ese sentido invitamos
para esta ocasión tres artistas teo
samudio que es un artista como les decía
de origen mexicano muy joven que trabaja
en medios digitales mucho el marketing
eventos en vivo digitales en fin
instalaciones y ediciones de todo tipo
de la imagen
en la actualidad rodrigo que nos va a
hablar perdón y estoy hablando en
francés
rodrigo ya es una intermitencia también
cultural que se va permeando rodrigo que
nos va hablar un poquito de su práctica
pero que que también es está atravesada
por voces indígenas por historias
esculturales que compartes y que pones
en arte digital y a esta dignora casalco
que trabaja en una mezcla yo creo muy
afortunada entre artesanía pintura y
mitos originarios de las américas va muy
bien
rodrigo y tú en tanto que artista bueno
explícanos un poquitito tu trabajo claro
yo soy músico diseñador gráfico pero
también he estado explorando como muchos
cruces entre la imagen el sonido y los
medios digitales específicamente a
través de escribir código entonces como
me re básico del código es más como
desde un enfoque más poético como jugar
con el lenguaje y ver qué posibilidades
tiene como de desdoblarse un proceso y
llevarme a lugares que son insospechados
incluso para mi código computacional
exacto
[Música]
pues básicamente solo es ahora muy de
moda algoritmos entonces en sí son como
series de pasos que la computadora puede
entender y como para crear una
no sé por ejemplo un pastel no hay como
una receta en la que tú tienes como que
ir creando ciertas o siguiendo ciertas
instrucciones y tienes como ciertos
elementos entonces es un poco como un
lenguaje que le dice a la computadora
como aquí están todos estos elementos y
ahora quiero que primero hagas esto y
luego lo otro pero en este proceso como
yo tampoco estudio del todo código para
mismo intuitivo es mucho como de jugar
con los elementos y a veces quizás no
llego al pastel que estoy queriendo pero
llegó a uno nuevo que es conjugado esto
que interinamente
[Risas]
y bueno en la exposición estoy
como jugando como más bien también de
algún modo de una forma como como mucho
agradecimiento y
con mucho respeto como moviendo algunos
poemas que encontré en que fueron
hallados en códices justo pero son de un
libro llamado quince poetas del mundo
náhuatl
miguel león-portilla a básicamente
cuatro son no tres son de él y uno más
de un libro llamado cantares mexicanos y
de estos poemas lo que hice es como
jugar con ellos en la web
y cómo crear movimientos del texto
entonces el texto de los poemas está en
náhuat el pero está todo el tiempo como
el flujo moviéndose mucho como en olas
entonces como tiene mucho que ver con la
importancia del agua para las culturas
nativas sobre todo para la cultura
azteca y toda esta como relevancia y
también jugué mucho como con los
imaginarios de estas culturas como
algunos simbolismos algunas imágenes que
ellos utilizaban para representar estas
palabras entonces es como una especie de
la experiencia algo como como de como si
cada poema fuera un mundo abstracto y
esto va a estar proyectado en el sitio
pero el mercado continuamente o vas
hacer presentaciones puntuales en
ciertos anales continuamente y va a
haber un teclado en donde los usuarios
pueden controlar las pruebas y navegar
entre ellos
entonces estoy donde la exposición es
excelente pregunta 3 en la sala de
difusión de parque extensión que está en
la calle de sant roc y
bueno en montreal es a partir del 5 de
septiembre y va a estar hasta el 13 de
octubre y bueno esperemos que también
tenga una vida en largo probablemente
estamos hablar leer una exposición
virtual estamos pensando estamos
desarrollando ideas en un primer tiempo
queremos que sea una exposición
intinerante que se presente en otros
lugares aquí en montreal y por qué no el
proyecto de rodrigo que ya tiene una
vida propia en la web podría ser como
una beta explorar nuestros programas
puntualmente cómo está en la red sale y
ahí tenemos mucha gente y nos mira desde
afuera para poder mostrarle este tipo de
audiencia a la gente de afuera que no
tiene la posibilidad de viajar a
montreal para poder vivirlo en carne
propia
sí sí sí yo creo que es a explorar y la
idea se nos queda para poder poder
trabajar en eso nada más yo ya venía un
poco a la idea de dzeko dice que es
justamente la idea de la escritura y la
de hacer este juego entre el códice
tradicional mesoamericano y el código
computacional que es un lenguaje
bueno
para darme una mejor idea es realmente
ir a verlo por ejemplo los otros
artistas que decías que mezclaban la
artesanía una de ellas que soy la
artesanía con chip si leen para darles
una imagen un poquito más esté más clara
de lo que van a ver en la exposición yo
les diría que la exposición está
concebida como una gran instalación que
el donde se integran un poco como a
nivel de constelación diferentes
lenguajes diferentes discursos no una
hay 22 proyectos que será el dt o
samudio y el tuyo rodrigo si estás de
acuerdo son más bien instalaciones que
son más bien inmersivas en en esta idea
de un poco lo que decían del mural del
guernica que tiene esta esta relación
de impacto como si entraras a un espacio
por la escala entonces hay una dimensión
de instalación inmersiva en el proyecto
de d
dt o continuo rodrigo idea que también
hay un nivel de interacción justo por el
teclado donde las imágenes van
desfilando y valencia- gestionando bien
es inmersivo e interactivo y el trabajo
de dinora también tiene de alguna manera
un nivel de inmersión en la escala de
los son como grandes mándala hechos con
pintura que va a inspirarse de
transiciones por ejemplo visto las con
pequeños puntos pequeños elementos con
colores muy vivos pero también tiene
niveles y para el madridismo motion
augura así entonces hay cabezas de
repente de venados que salen nos están
mirando y dentro de la boca aparece un
rostro por ejemplo son muy surrealistas
pero más en un imaginario indígena yo
diría uy sol tal vez esté mixteca
en fin atraviesa muchas vertientes pero
sería como escultura escultopintura si
podemos decirlo así dimensión
tridimensional que hace de alguna manera
sí que hacer alguna manera o una
apropiación del espacio que realmente y
la estructura es la estructura de un
códice el montaje está pensado también
para ser y tú eres la curadora de esa
exposición por lo que estoy viendo pues
es digamos compleja en términos
artísticos para para los neófitos pero
cuál es el desafío para ti en tanto que
curadora una exposición como ésta
realmente es un reto fascinante yo no
termino de aprender de este oficio la
curaduría es yo diría es una creación
una creación con los artistas y
ávidamente con el público también porque
a veces hay preguntas que nos que nos
hacen reflexionar y aprender en el
camino yo diría que el reto es poner a
dialogar es construir un discurso
tiene una idea muy clara y poner a
dialogar las obras que existen ya en
este caso son artistas latino
quebequense latino canadienses porque
dinorah viven en más bien en la región
de ottawa latino pero la idea es que
como percibir el interés de ciertos
artistas común en ciertos temas a partir
de eso generar un discurso ir a buscar
las obras y hacer justamente los
antiguos planes narrativa la venta de
datos y para ti
rodrigo el desafío de presentar tu obra
en esta exposición
yo suelo trabajar más en el performance
en vivo así lo algo que se llama life
coding entonces como modificó el código
y eso genera improviso sonidos o música
pero en este sentido es más como pensar
en la experiencia que va a tener la
persona que va al museo no y que juega
con estas teclas entras como pensar eso
creo que es como como algo nuevo para mí
que me emociona mucho y también por otro
lado decidí que por lo regular solo
proyectar en espacios como cuadrados que
es como lo más normal en las
computadoras pero esta vez justo como
por establecer un diálogo una
conversación interesante entre con las
demás piezas propuse cómo proyectar en
un círculo entonces es la primera vez
que dice algo así y por suerte un amigo
también me está ayudando y vemos como ya
ha logrado mapear el círculo entonces
eso fue como también pues un reto pero
creo que la experiencia más linda es
como la parte de como
la retroalimentación que hay entre las
obras como en los diálogos que se pueden
crear entre ellas y quizás hasta como de
alguna manera me ayuda como a ver con
una mirada distinta o desde otra
perspectiva lo que hice hoy y como eso
creo que puede empujar a otros lugares
esta misma obra y eso es muy bien
entonces pues para los que nos están
escuchando aquí en montreal la
exposición comienza el jueves 5 de
septiembre hasta el 13 de octubre en la
sala de difusión de parques canción y
421 calle sant roc
leonardo hay alguna reacción con un
saludo se décima el zamora saludos desde
méjico javier gonzález no agrediese para
uno de los dos pablo más barrios y los
invitados saludos y un abrazo de
guadalajara me parece muy interesante el
programa felicidades y luís alfredo
marín dice que bueno volver a verlos
dios les continúe bendiciendo y
guardando hoy siempre les saludo desde
santiago en quebec
bueno pues muy bien
muchas gracias por haberse desplazado no
se vayan no los estoy poniendo en la
cuenta pero muchísimas gracias por
haberse desplazado pues sí mucho éxito
nos veremos el 5 allá en el día de la
inauguración de la exposición y bueno
pues sí mucho éxito muchas gracias veces
y continuamos entonces acá antes de
entrar de lleno al en el programa mi
querido leonardi gama en la que
vamos a hablar de hay novedades con
nuestra aplicación
no la novedad es que la tiene que seguir
bajando es porque la aplicación en
realidad es básicamente una puerta de
entrada mucho más rápida a la navegación
de nuestro sitio y esa es la invitación
que le hacemos otra la gente que se
acerque que van a nuestro sitio internet
arriba a la derecha está la publicidad o
sea ustedes dan clic en el banner del
pequeño banner que ahí y entra en la
página donde tienen las dos
posibilidades bajar tanto la aplicación
para android como para para rato
la historia es esta aplicación les da la
posibilidad de tener el contenido
en la mano guardar poder
reservar cosas para leer después si mi
problema de presbicia lo quiero poner
más grande tengo la posibilidad de
agrandar las letras el auto problema
pero después por ejemplo otra de las
cosas pueden ver este programa este
programa en directo vive en directo a
partir de la aplicación así que los
invito a que van a nuestro sitio
recintonet punto sea y hagan clic en el
banner donde dice aplicación de rci y
pueden bajarla en cualquiera de las
lenguas estando bajando la aplicación en
lengua española usted tiene el acceso a
la lengua francesa e inglesa y así
sucesivamente para las otras lenguas
siempre lenguas oficiales están
presentes son el francés y el inglés en
el caso nuestro directamente uno podría
ver las cosas más importantes de las
otras lenguas para la gente que vive
aquí en con la en canadá que habla
español y otro idioma cualquiera de las
dos lenguas oficiales así que tienen la
posibilidad de hacer eso y también la
aplicación insiste en los otros dos
idiomas de radio canadá internacional
árabe y kim exacto árabe chino francés
inglés y español así que para cualquiera
que quiera bajarlos tienen todas las
opciones
[Música]
exacto aquellos que quieran practicar
árabe manda bien tienen la posibilidad
de hacerlo con la aplicación fantástico
bueno vamos a pasar a los temas que
resaltamos esta semana y después con el
tiempo que nos quede pues lo
aprovecharemos de otra forma eleonora
chapman no se encuentra con nosotros
está esta tarde pero ella los invita a
escuchar una entrevista que hizo con
santiago escobar del sindicato de
trabajadores unidos de la alimentación y
el comercio de canadá que explica lo que
significa el permiso de trabajo abierto
para los trabajadores al parecer es algo
nuevo yo estuve ausente así que no estoy
muy al tanto de eso no sé si para lo
maestro tienes alguna idea de lo que
hice siempre pues brevemente es que te
acuerdas que existe un programa de
trabajadores temporales que vienen y que
vienen generalmente con un solo
empleador bueno a partir de ya creo
este es el permiso abierto lo que
permite es que la gente que viene dentro
del marco de este programa no solamente
venga con un empleador sino que pueda
cambiar si quiere exactamente entonces
por eso es abierto porque lo que puede
cambiar de empleador si quiere o si
necesita lo cual se prestaba a
explotación de estos trabajadores que
vienen de distintos lugares del centro y
sudamérica y sobre todo de méxico y
trabajar acá bueno muy bien
leonardo tú
nos hablas de google y del desarrollo de
una inteligencia sea una cosa bien
estancia artificial medio rara realidad
yo explicaba antes trataba explicarte
que sólo le falta las alas no suelen le
falta el asado y es mi predilección
porque a mí me encantan tres cosas que
me fascina en la vida son el fútbol las
cuestiones tecnológicas y el asado el
asado no está en la sala está primero
acá primero obviamente pero bolt y
después en la carlos es uno de los
sectores de google que tiene un
laboratorio de estudio bien particular
está estudiando algoritmos de
inteligencia artificial y ahora lo va a
hacer por intermedio del fútbol lo que
ellos quieren en realidad está este
laboratorio llamado deep main ya lo hizo
con otros juegos que son mucho más
fáciles o mucho más digamos simples en o
valerosos y previsibles exactamente lo
que están haciendo justamente es
intentar enseñarle a los algoritmos de
inteligencia artificial que puedan
prever qué es lo que puede pasar los
escenarios que tienen digamos la
posibilidad de aprender a cual cualquier
lo que me espera si yo hago esto que es
la como esperas el agua que está que son
escenarios que no están en la
programación de viaje o salga el salto
en este caso lo que están haciendo lo
que hace de imagen en ahora es acaba de
hacer un juego de fútbol que está basado
en la programación del fifa 2019 y del
pro evolution soccer que son los dos
juegos uno de microsoft y el otro de
sony que son los juegos más populares en
cuanto a jugar el fútbol
juegos de vídeo y lo que están haciendo
es han aplicado dentro del juego estos
algoritmos de estos agentes de
inteligencia artificial para poder
reconocer las variables y las
posibilidades para que estos pequeños
programitas aprendan qué es lo que puede
pasar o estar digamos atentos a lo que
puede venir sin que necesariamente lo
sepan fue un juego que
de hecho disparó una bala y le pega a
algo digamos que el algoritmo lo puede
identificar cuál es la trayectoria de
todo lo que viene en el campo en el caso
del fútbol son 11 elementos que tienen
que interior es total en 22 en total que
tienen características diferentes a los
jugadores que son especialistas para
patear penales hay otros para patear
tiros libres a otros personas quiero
solamente otros que hacen muy buenos
pases otros que tienen velocidad
entonces coordinar todo esto para poder
enseñarle a los algoritmos de
inteligencia artificial a que reconozcan
lo que puede venir es una tarea bastante
interesante en realidad lo están
haciendo porque los resultados van a
mejorar la capacidad de los algoritmos a
aprender cosas imprevisibles pero no
habrá algo detrás de todo esto porque si
le enseñamos a la máquina a reflexionar
a tomar iniciativas digamos que no están
en el retrato que no están en las
programaciones de eso después eso hay
que preguntarle al creador de teclas más
de todo eso el que esté en contra de
todo esto decir que dice que la
inteligencia artificial es un peligro
extraordinario para la mente es una
discusión filosófica muy compleja
sobre entendimiento porque a partir del
momento en que la máquina comienza a
reflexionar ya tomar decisiones
la gente ya pasó no me acuerdo son un
mal contexto y qué empresa había
empezado a hacer análisis como con el
tema de antecedentes artificiales ve que
he creado dos códigos con dos
computadoras diferentes se comunican
entre ellas está bien inteligencia
artificial que había aprendido le habían
programado y está también en un momento
dado empezaron a conectarse en un
lenguaje que no entendía
apagaron las computadoras destino porque
cuando empiezan a hacer algo que uno no
entiende track está fuera está fuera así
que apagan anotadora
pero me hace pensar dice del espacio
que había escrito un cuento de ciencia
ficción donde el gps que tenía
inteligencia artificial se enamoraba del
conductor entonces cuando el pasado
novia
cuando pasó nos mandaban lugares medios
raros para que la novia todas las
sorpresas que nos puede reservar la
nueva tecnología pero paloma contigo
vamos a bajarnos de las nuevas
tecnologías y vamos a ir acá
a algo más concreto y es de una el caso
de esta multinacional que pensé en ese
en ese la vall en que fue demandada en
chile
exactamente recibió una demanda por
parte de una compañía más pequeña
chilena que el acusado no filial en
realidad era subcontratada por sn se la
valen que es una gran compañía
canadiense que está en medio de todos
los escándalos por el momento en este
momento incluso el mundo en todo el
mundo pero incluso ahora el primer
ministro canadiense ha tenido que
defenderse por haber defendido a la
compañía de alguna manera entonces bueno
ese es el aval en en en chile tiene
inversiones con la compañía principal
de minería de cobre en chile que es
codelco que es además una empresa minera
pública de chile entonces ese es el aval
en tenía contratos con con esta compañía
que codelco rompió y sn se la valen
había subcontratado a compañías chilenas
más pequeñas para construir la
infraestructura para los proyectos que
tenían con con codelco todo eso para
decir que ese no le pagó a una empresa
en particular y a otras pero una de las
que está implicada particularmente es
tecno cis que es una compañía chilena y
esa compañía llevó a ese es el aval en a
la corte y el juzgado el 19 juzgado de
santiago decretó la liquidación forzosa
de la empresa canadiense y con eso
pues tiene que lo obliga de alguna
manera a pagar sus deudas con las
empresas pequeñas pero además de esta
causa que es una causa civil hay una
causa penal que también en la que
también está involucrada es en xela vale
en chile por fraude por alrededor de 7
mil millones de pesos
[Música]
lo que sí sé es que le debe a tecno sis
por ejemplo 18 mil 500 millones de pesos
y lo que son 34 millones de dólares
canadienses trafica si es plata y además
hay muchos otros acreedores de ese ente
cnc la belle en chile entonces bueno
hablamos con el abogado de esta compañía
pequeña chilena que llevó a juicio a ese
en ese la belen y que ganó por el
momento la primera etapa lo que sí nos
contestó
por supuesto que hablamos tratamos de
hablar con la agencia de ese con ese en
ese ya no nos respondieron que habían
pedido a la justicia chilena de tener
las siguientes etapas del proceso porque
lo consideran sin fundamento entonces
está todavía en
lo que va a pasar a largo plazo pero
bueno no ser una compañía canadiense
como muchas otras que hay que está
presente en américa latina bueno
excelente va a haber un seguimiento y
probablemente esté exactamente entonces
bueno por momento estamos ahí en esta
etapa y estaría interesante que la gente
escuchara la entrevista con el abogado
viera la respuesta de sn es el aval en
para que se vayan haciendo una idea
porque esta compañía está presente en
muchas regiones del mundo y esa
entrevista la pueden escuchar en rcn
punto se sitúa en la aplicación baja sí
pero antes de que yo pasé a lo que yo
vengo los saludos en este caso
el samur de méxico javier martínez
allows saludos desde el valle del yaqui
en california
[Música]
del valle del yaqui que nosotros decimos
el valle del yaqui y pablo no es
probablemente le diga al valle del yaqui
y entonces no va a suceder así yo soy
como las nuevas tecnologías
[Música]
bueno entonces yo por mi parte los
invito a escuchar una entrevista que
hice justamente esta semana con un
intelectual un profesor en el
departamento de estudios literarios de
la universidad de quebec en montreal
antonio domínguez leiva no sé si lo
conoces antonio que es especialista en
cultura popular
estuvimos conversando justamente esta
semana sobre la última película de
tarantino érase una vez en con entonces
él hace una lectura muy interesante y
muy particular de esta película porque
la sitúa en ese contexto todos ustedes
son muchísimo más jóvenes que yo
entonces él es bueno escuchar eso para
ver las referencias que se evocan y que
en la película aparecen que si no las
conoces muy bien se pasa del hablar de
dar igual o sea yo he escuchado dos o
tres análisis de la película
un analista a un crítico que debe estar
rozando los 70 años y uno que tiene 35
40 y el de 35 40 le gustó igual la
película pero hay un montón de
referencias muy finas con respecto al
entorno con cosas que pasan
específicamente la película con niños es
donde da menos historia las cositas
escondidas que están dentro de él
el término se aplica para las sorpresas
en los juegos de vídeo en este caso en
las películas también funcionan son
referencias muy finas a cosas que ya
pasaron y que dan una perspectiva de la
película muy interesante así que sería
interesantes le dije a pablo que iba a
ver a leer la entrevista y la revista
para ver interés cosas voices para poder
leerla mejor no sé si porque bueno habla
de una época eso fue en 1969 yo tenía 18
años en aquella época y ya me estaba
volviendo hippie
pero no estaba en la en la categoría de
hippie que es representada en la
película que es la banda de la familia
de charles manson que era un frustrado
que de alguna forma pues quería vengarse
de un productor que
rechazó su proyecto de música porque él
tenía pretensiones de músico y había
grabado un demo y se lo había presentado
a este productor y el productor se lo
rechazó entonces él quería vengarse de
ese productor y eso se ve ahí
no sólo de ella
sharon state se encontraba en la casa de
ese tipo entonces murió pues
sin tener nada que ver con el pase ese
murió
entonces es la forma como como la
película es tratada que es en ese
hollywood de esa época que está en pleno
cambio con el cine la televisión dos
actores un actor principal que es di
caprio y él y su doble que también se
encuentran en todos y en realidad de dos
soles leimotiv pero van contando toda la
historia que va pasando alrededor de sí
entonces es muy interesante la lectura
que que antonio domínguez leiva hace de
ese de ese programa de esa película y se
nos fue el tiempo como agua entre los
dedos siempre nos quedan sólo 40
segundos finalmente para nuestros
invitados un muy rápidamente una
despedida pues adiós desear que estén
bien y que tenga un buen fin de semana
técnicos hoy duran marca andrés de jean
pierre
leonardo paloma martínez y una persona y
bueno pues vamos a pedir que nos alargue
en estas dos horas para poder a mí me
queda una pregunta de la ciencia que
estaba pensando en una antes de sangre
que averigua cuando nos vamos a morir no
quiero saberlo yo no voy a morir pero sí
quiero decirles que la semana próxima
nos vemos nuevamente aquí en este
programa adiós sab
e
[Música]